This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
Sign up for the CuriosityStream/Nebula bundle
deal to watch the extended cut of this video
with everything we cut for time at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.
Supermarkets are a marvel obscured by banality.
Nearly everyone in the developed world uses
them regularly, so we have no basis of comparison—we
just don’t know a world without supermarkets.
We don’t know how it was a century ago,
when grocery stores took the form of small
storefronts, found every few blocks throughout
towns and cities.
You’d hand the clerk a list indicating you
wanted, among other things, apples.
They’d then gather you apples—assuming
they were in season and in stock.
Nowadays, however, you are confronted by an
aisle rivaling the size of those historic
grocery stores, displaying a tantalizing,
sprawling selection of Honeycrips, Fujis,
Granny Smiths, Galas, Braeburns, and more—all
the varieties, always in stock, all year long.
They sit next to pineapples from Costa Rica,
avocados from Mexico, and mangos from Brazil.
Further on, there’s beef from an entirely
different hemisphere, and fish that was alive
in an ocean thousands of miles away just days
ago.
A century ago, you could certainly buy a jar
of peanut butter, but now, you can buy regular
peanut butter, or chunky peanut butter, or
smooth peanut butter, or organic peanut butter—and
it doesn’t stop there.
You can get the chunky Jif brand, or the chunky
Smucker’s brand, or the Skippy brand, the
store brand, or one of so many more.
You have dozens upon dozens of choices of
peanut butter, dozens of choices of other
nut butter, dozens of choices of other sandwich
spreads, and all of that is just one part
of one aisle.
Put together, the stability and variety of
choice in modern supermarkets is incredible.
In big cities and small towns alike, American
supermarkets offer an average of some 30,000
different product choices which stay in-stock
about 92% of the time.
While the concept of the modern supermarket
first appeared in the US, it's since proliferated
across the entire developed world.
The fact that this has become not only normal,
but expected globally is the greatest indicator
of the robustness of the modern global supply
chain, but that’s not to say that it’s
easy.
For consumers, it’s simple—we can get
everything we want, anytime, from a single
store—but the complexity behind that is
truly stunning.
This is a typical American supermarket—a
City Market brand store in Glenwood Springs,
Colorado.
While this brand is small, it’s part of
the larger King Soopers brand, which itself
is part of Kroger’s—the largest American
supermarket company.
The entire American supermarket landscape
is incredibly consolidated, with the top four
companies holding 45% of the market, which
certainly has massively negative consequences,
but this market concentration has led to the
huge scale and complexity of our current food
supply chain.
Even independent grocers now tend to rely
on gigantic cooperatives to amass buying power
and supply their shelves, so industry-wide,
scale and complexity is the norm.
Now, supermarkets like this are involved with
a perpetual balancing act.
Keeping items in stock is of paramount financial
concern—research into the matter has found
that on the third instance of a desired item
being out of stock, consumers will go to an
alternate store 70% of the time.
Being located just five minutes from a Walmart,
this store can’t afford to go out of stock
of a single item, push a customer to a competitor,
and lose out on thousands of dollars in annual
sales because they decide they like Walmart
more.
Therefore, the task is to keep everything
in stock as much as possible, while having
as little extra product as possible.
So, the way this Glenwood Springs City Market,
along with essentially any grocery store,
keeps those 30,000 products continuously on
its shelves is simple, at least on the surface.
You see, every item in a supermarket is labeled
with a barcode—usually that code is standardized
industry-wide, except with some white-label
products.
When products arrive at the store, they are
checked in to its inventory management software.
From there, it’s simple math—as products
are checked out and paid for, they’re subtracted
from the inventory count, and as that count
gets low, the store knows it’s time to reorder.
It’s a straightforward concept—except
when you actually implement it in the real
world.
There’s more than one way a product can
leave a store—it can get stolen, go bad,
get damaged, or more.
That means there’s always a slight disparity
between how many items there are on paper,
and in reality.
Inventory management software can account
for some of that, assuming employees feed
it accurate data, but stores also conduct
a manual count every month or two to determine
the actual disparity.
This is most important for financial reporting
reasons—the retailer can’t know how profitable
it actually is until it knows how much product
it lost—but it can also be used to tell
the inventory management software how much
it’s typically off, and correct for that
in the future to make sure re-orders happen
on time.
Then, there are other factors.
For example, if a supermarket runs a sale
on a given item, that product will likely
sell more, so inventory management software
needs to account for that in its ordering
process to make sure that it correspondently
ramps inventory up.
Then, incoming unseasonably warm weather could
mean that barbecue charcoal sales, for example,
are about to increase, while hot chocolate
sales will decrease, so more complex inventory
management software can account for external
factors like these and make ordering decisions
based upon them.
Now, some products are simple to keep in stock.
Oreos, for example, have a long shelf live
and come from a massive manufacturer with
multiple production facilities spread out
across the world.
There’s plenty of slack and flexibility
in that system.
That’s not the case with all foods.
Take, for example, grapes.
Table grapes are quite difficult to keep in
stock.
If there’s a sudden surge in demand for
grapes, you can’t just order more from the
factory—their global inventory levels are
essentially decided years before as growers
decide whether to add or subtract vines from
their vineyards.
What’s more, grapes are highly seasonal.
They don’t ripen off the vine, so they have
to be picked exactly when they’re best for
eating—effectively meaning growers have
a one or two week window to get a given vineyard
harvested.
Of course, grapes are found in grocery stores
for far more than two weeks a year—in fact
they’re almost always available.
What makes that possible is a massive production
cycle spanning across the entire western hemisphere.
Now, the easy part of the year for the Glenwood
Springs City Market to get its grapes is late
summer.
That’s because California’s central valley,
where the vast majority of the country’s
grapes are grown, has its natural harvest
season between mid-August and late-September.
That’s extended earlier into July by “ultra-early
season” varieties of grapes, such as Sharada
UA, and then later into November by late-season
varieties such as the “autumn king.”
Therefore, there’s about a four-month window
when the entire country’s grape supply is
largely fulfilled by California.
Once that ends, though, things get trickier,
but the industry has learned to take advantage
of global climate patterns.
Peru, thanks to its fairly equatorial climate,
begins its harvest just when California’s
ends, early-December, and saturates the market
until mid-February, when Chile, with its more
seasonal climate, takes over.
They essentially act as the southern-hemisphere
equivalent of California, also using early
and late season varieties to stretch their
massive harvest all the way until May.
Next, California’s Imperial and Coachella
valleys, as well as various locations in Mexico,
fire-up their harvests.
These areas have year-round warm weather that
allows for a year-round growing season, but
time their vineyards specifically to line
up with this gap in the market until mid-July,
when California’s more seasonal Central
Valley begins its harvest—starting the cycle
once again.
While the overall path a given food product
takes varies dramatically, the one constant
is that every item that ends up on the Glenwood
Springs City Market’s shelves comes via
here—the distribution center.
Now, how distribution centers work on the
surface level is fairly standard—they bring
in pallets of a single product, break them
down to the box level, and create pallets
with smaller quantities of everything a store
needs.
How each distribution center accomplishes
that, however, differs.
Kroger’s Aurora facility, operated by a
company called Windigo Logistics, uses a fairly
high degree of automation.
Trucks arrive from all across North America,
delivering pallets worth of product from Kroger’s
different vendors.
For example, a truck might arrive from Nabisco’s
plant in Chicago carrying pallets worth of
Oreos.
These pallets are immediately placed on an
induction conveyor belt, where a scanner determines
what they actually are.
With that information, the warehousing software
determines whether it thinks it will need
more Oreos in its system in the next three
days, or later.
If the answer’s later, the pallets just
make a quick stop at a pallet exchanger machine,
which swaps each onto a fresh storage pallet,
before the conveyor belts take them to an
automated longer-term storage system in a
separate part of the warehouse.
If one pallet worth of Oreos is needed sooner,
though, it will go to a de-palletizing machine,
which breaks them down to the box level, each
of which carries dozens of units of the actual
product.
Those boxes are injected into a network of
conveyor belts, which takes them to a machine
that places each onto an individual tray.
That tray is then automatically stored somewhere
in a cavernous hall of shelving—essentially,
a massive vending machine.
Sometime in the next three days, some King
Soopers or City Market store will place a
re-order, indicating that they need Oreos,
and so the warehousing software will automatically
remove some trays of Oreos from the shelving
and place them on another conveyor belt, which
will take them to a smaller automated shelving
system closer to the palletizing area, which
acts as interim storage, keeping items no
more than a few hours.
Then, when it comes time to build an actual
pallet worth of product for a given store,
the trays are removed from the shelving in
a specific order.
You see, the system knows the composition
of the shelves of each of their stores, so
it knows what order to build a pallet in.
They’ll put items for one side of a store
aisle at the bottom of a pallet, items for
the middle of that aisle in the middle, and
items for the other end at the top.
That way, the stockers in the store can break
down a pallet, and put things immediately
on the shelves in the most efficient manner.
At the distribution center, this palletizing
process is still completely automated, and
in the end, the system will deliver completed
pallets to the humans responsible for loading
outbound trucks.
Finally, once that’s all completed, a truck
will take the three-hour journey west to Glenwood
Springs’ City Market, where an overnight
crew restocks the shelves with fresh product.
Now, even as automation is making significant
inroads, plenty of grocery distribution centers
still use a far more manual approach.
That process is essentially the same—pallets
are taken in, stored, and outbound pallets
are built with smaller quantities of each
product—but each step is just completed
by humans instead of machines.
However, both the automated and manual processes
are not perfect.
Specifically, they present an issue for what’s
referred to as “slow moving inventory.”
You see, grocery distribution centers are
traditionally configured to work by the pallet
load—it just isn’t efficient to take in
a smaller amount—but sometimes, products
just aren’t that popular.
However, unpopular products are actually crucial
to the business strategies of modern supermarkets.
The reason why they might have dozens upon
dozens of types of salsas is that some niche
brand on the bottom shelf is probably at least
one person’s favorite.
The City Market in Glenwood Springs might
carry that salsa, but the Walmart or Target
might not.
Even if that one consumer can get everything
else they need at one of the competitors,
they’re going to keep coming back to the
City Market because they know they can get
that one, niche product that they love.
Supermarkets view niche, slow-moving products
as key differentiators, and key to customer
retention, so they’re certainly willing
to sell these products even at a loss.
In fact, Walmart experimented with reducing
its product variety by 11%, but quickly reversed
course as it became clear that this ultimately
had a negative impact on their bottom line—even
if it simplified their distribution logistics.
On the warehouse side, though, if each store
that sells that niche salsa only sells a dozen
of them per week, it’s going to take quite
a while for even the entire company to work
their way through a single pallet.
In the distribution center, though, a single
pallet in the picking area takes the space
of a single pallet, regardless of whether
it’s used up in a day or a month.
Therefore, every additional niche product
stocked increases the amount of storage space
needed, and increases the overall distance
that pickers have to travel to assemble an
average pallet—in the case of manual warehouses.
To mitigate these effects, while still maintaining
their offerings of niche products, some supermarket
chains, including Kroger’s and H-E-B, have
set up entire, dedicated distribution systems
for slow-moving inventory.
By setting up these facilities, they can ship
out less than box-load shipments of certain
products, and stock them without slowing down
the process for fast-moving inventory.
Of course, this process does still require
a certain amount of scale to work better than
the alternative—while Kroger’s has set
it up in densely-populated areas of the US
east-coast, it has yet to do so in the more
sparsely-populated rockies region home to
their King Soopers and City Market brands.
There just isn’t enough overall demand in
the region to justify a dedicated setup.
The pure scale at which the supermarket industry
operates is what has led to this level of
supply-chain complexity.
When a single facility is responsible for
distributing a sizable portion of a state's
food supply, tiny, incremental efficiency
improvements can lead to huge savings for
companies.
While such commoditization and consolidation
of food supply is viewed as problematic by
many people, ultimately, the average consumer
just want a wide variety of food at a low-cost.
That’s what this system provides.
Any modern supply chain is molded into what
leads to commercial success, and as long as
people continue to view the convenience of
having 30,000 options of what to eat at a
moment’s notice as paramount, this is how
the developed world will continue to get their
food.
So, anyone who stayed to this point in the
video probably enjoys watching Wendover videos,
and would enjoy watching as much of them as
possible, but unfortunately, the YouTube algorithm
doesn’t feel the same.
For any channel, there’s a sweet spot of
video length—for us, it’s about 15 minutes—and
whenever we do anything longer than that,
the algorithm actually punishes us.
We always have to cut for time, but in order
to not feel like that work was for nothing,
we’ve started to upload extended cuts of
our videos, including this one, to Nebula—the
streaming site home to all your favorite educational
creators, founded by those same creators.
In addition, their unique business model allows
for big-budget projects, of which we’ve
made plenty across HAI and Wendover.
Of course, the best way to get access to Nebula
makes it even better.
Signing up through CuriosityStream’s bundle
deal means you also get access to CuriosityStream,
which is a fantastic streaming site that I
regularly use—home to a huge selection of
non-fiction TV shows and documentaries, such
as this one about the barcode, and how it
shaped our modern economy.
If this video, about the supermarket industry,
was interesting to you, this short documentary
is a fantastic addendum diving deep into how
modern retail works.
Best of all, signing up for this bundle deal
helps independent creators like us stay independent.
It can all be had, both streaming sites, for
the rather crazy price of less than $15 a
year with the current sale at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.